now over to this year's oscars oh here
we go co-host wanda sykes who will take
the stage alongside regina hall and amy
schumer now it was previously announced
that the show yes will return with a
host for the first time since jimmy
kimmel went back to back in 2017 and
2018. that's right want to stop by jimmy
kimmel live and talked all about her
latest gig with jimmy telling her she's
getting robbed after revealing what he
got paid to host
out of all the jobs that i have this one
is actually going to cost me money it is
going to cost you money because can you
will you say how much you get paid for
this do you even know i don't even know
it's like a scale probably it's less
than that it's less than that yeah it's
i got paid fifteen thousand dollars to
host the office oh my god okay and
there's one of me you guys are probably
yeah we got to split that
which
you know it sounds like a lot for one
night but it's months of work leading up
to it yes yeah that's a lot of work yeah
you're getting robbed you should you
know what hold out right now because
they need hosts i've already decided i'm
just going to steal an oscar
[Laughter]
will you drink during the show
uh
probably after the first act after the
first act you'll have some drinks i
probably will oh that's yeah because
cause you get you know you get the big
part out the way right and then i'm like
i'm here to have some fun it's not like
i'm getting paid you know right
speaking of cause you're gonna get what
you pay for you want soap rwanda you
better you had to add some more zeros
and move that comma that's right what
i'm saying
you get you getting free wanda
i love watercycles
uh were you shocked at that number 15
grand i was because i don't think i ever
gave it much thought how much someone
gets paid to be the host of one of those
shows right and when that came up i was
like right would you get paid because it
is the one night but then yummy you know
from hosting events it's not it's never
just the thing well no and this is i
mean working with your own writers like
how many people are involved in kimmel's
performance who are supposedly covered
by that same 15 grand
i had assumed for a long time that it
was zero that it was almost treated like
the super bowl halftime show but then
you realize that it is a union show it
is all this stuff so you have to pay
them something so when wanda sykes said
scale or or less than scale i don't know
what that would be when you're sort of
at that at that level
but yeah 15 grand for for one night i
understand that is a lot of money 15
grand for two months is a lot of money
but
15 grand to host the show that is one of
the most watched events in television
every single year is not a lot of fun
it's relative to what we're looking at
right like it does sound like quite a
bit
but when you think about who has hosted
the show and what the show means the
buzz around it how everyone talks about
it all year round like
you would think
that that person might get paid a bit
more than that yeah yeah so like did so
billy crystal did it all those years for
that or did were they paying billy moore
you think
he must have been able to get more as he
went along maybe that's why they're
always like let's get a new host this
year right so they don't have to
negotiate with the same person more
every single year right and you have to
be nuts in order to do it more than once
for that kind of money oh a hundred
percent right like how much do you
really love
being there if you're doing it for that
kind of money every single time